des salariés qui se suicident à cause
des difficultés au travail le phénomène
semble prendre de l'ampleur il y a
quelques semaines on avait par exemple
évoqué plusieurs cas chez renault à
guyancourt dans les yvelines un chinon
également plusieurs employés de la
centrale nucléaire ont mis fin à leur
jour récemment l'un de ces suicides est
examiné par la justice séverine
bourgault et marc felix
située en rase campagne non loin de
chinon la centrale nucléaire edf s'est
ainsi placée sous haute surveillance
derrière ces cheminées qui crachent leur
fumée se cache un profond malaise
partagé par les 1300 salariés
80 copains qui sont conseil de
discipline en ce moment comme la faisant
diverses et variées
des fautes professionnelles les foutent
des motifs de grève
sur
un site récemment endeuillée par le
suicide d'un cadre de 50 ans l'homme
avait des hautes responsabilités dans la
conduite des réacteurs il s'agit du
troisième suicide depuis août 2006 du
quatrième depuis l'été 2004 pour le
docteur ways aucun doute edf est
responsable ça fait plusieurs années au
moins quatre ans que de façon
progressive on tire de plus en plus fort
la sonnette d'alarmé s'il faut mettre en
en inaptitude professionnelle
tous les gens qui sont en difficulté au
jour d'aujourd'hui j'ai fait les comptes
sur les 400 personnes que je suis je
devrais en m 111 inaptes au travail
à l'écart de la centrale de salariés ont
accepté de nous rencontrer pour
témoigner de leur souffrance
j'en passe sont plus en fait je me
demande encore une fois que je me
demande encore d'auxerre
parce que c'est ce que je disais
gg le ch est vraiment lente 6,2 me remet
à nos
sociétés je peux vous dire que la
qualité de vie au travail c'est
véritablement une préoccupation très
forte d'edf ce que nous voulons c'est
continuer parce que nous faisons déjà
mais continuer à mettre l'humain au
centre de nos préoccupations managériale
qu'il s'agisse de gestion de la
performance ou qu'il s'agisse de
relations avec les individus le lien
entre suicides et conditions de travail
est très difficile à établir mais selon
les syndicats les médecins se seraient
30 à 40% du personnel qui se répand
souffrance à la centrale nucléaire de
chinon